i love how brandy said
someone asked me
are you winona or bett
it was a highlight of her career she
says
so she chose me
and i was bet bet we love you it's so
strange
in a way to be here but it seems so
natural at the same time
i've lived my life publicly since i was
17.
so it feels natural to be
with my family of choice
and
tonight is a celebration
and at the same time
i can't put into words how
devastated i am
it's the first place i've been publicly
i said goodbye to her two weeks ago and
kissed her on the forehead
i know i know i know you do
her eyebrows were still perfect
she was unlike anyone in our family
and i miss her so
much
but i will continue to sing i said i
would and
i can't imagine
it's a light of mine i'm going to let it
shine
not sure where or when but it's going to
shine
and with your help
so
oh knock it off
[Applause]
so i made a decision when i thought i'd
share it on national television
[Music]
then after a lot of thought
i'm gonna
have to honor her
and do this to her i'm just going to
have to
because
that's what you would want
[Music]
and bono once told me give them what
they want not what you want
plus there are 2 500 roses up here
so tonight
as we close
i say and the show must go on
as hard as it may be
and we will show up together
and you will carry me as you carried me
for 38 years once again because
i honestly didn't think i could do it
just like in 19
i didn't know if i could go on without
her
oh god
life is so strange
it's so devastatingly beautiful what
happened here tonight
so we will continue this
spectacle
[Music]
that's what she would want right